hello again
it's windmill wednesday and i'm trevor
and we're here again outside the
windmill because we're not allowed to go
inside
i thought this time might sort of say
try and tell you a little bit about what
uh how the mill
would have worked so we've got six
floors in the windmill of which
four we can physically visit uh but the
other two
are not allowed to visit too narrow up
there and too dangerous
so we'll start the ground floor so if
you go through the front doors
this is where the grain would have been
brought in from the farms etc
and there would have been a desk and
somebody to to weigh off
the uh the grain as it arrived to make
sure they all weighed correctly in the
sacks
probably as much as 200 pound per sec
one heck of a size uh and then they'll
be hoisted
all through all the floors all the way
to the top of the mill
so on the next floor up is our museum
floor it's the second floor
and uh and we would uh this is where the
miller works it's really the command
center
and he above his head would have been
hanging from the ceiling
an enormous great big what is known as
the giant spur wheel
full of gearing covered in gearing
taking bring all the power from the
sails will be brought down to that
that one wheel now from that stone nuts
would operate
all the other machinery in the mill
including on the floor above it
which was where the stones were located
okay so the uh on on the second floor as
i say there was the three sets of there
was three sets of stones
two were for a million grain and they
were the best stones and they were made
from french burst
the other set of stones uh was made from
derbyshire gritstone and just outside
the middle you'll see one of the stones
that was
the only one that remains and that's one
that's used for the domestic grits don't
want to use from
the byproducts and adding to other
meal to make animal feed
uh above the uh the next floor which is
the highest point we can go to
uh is was known as the pin floor so all
the grain has gone all the way to the
top of the mill above the bin floor
so the grain could be to be stored so
the grain to be fed into the mill
into the bins to feed the stones below
and and the miller below that is
operating
all the machinery from from there
okay so the two floors at the top of the
mill which we can't visit
uh one is where i just said the uh the
grain was stored prior to it
uh being tipped into the bins to start
the process but above that
there's a low ceiling area known as the
dust floor now the dust floor is there
generally just
trying to minimize any debris that could
get in through the cap
some a bird can fly in even a bee could
fly in
that don't any of that getting into the
process so the dust floor
minimizes that risk and then above that
of course we've got the cap
and the cap resembles an upturned boat
or looks like a wagon
and at the rear of that is the fan tail
now the fan tail is designed just to
catch the minimum amount of wind
and freely turn the cap into the wind so
the sails are always
facing the wind if the mill wasn't
working and you walk through the front
doors
you may even hear it creaking like a
haunted house
because the rollers are trying
desperately or the phantom
is trying desperately to turn the
rollers and turn the cap into the wind
well that was just a quick run down as
to how the mill operated such a big mill
and so many flaws it spread out somewhat
that our process
spread out so widely well that's it for
today thanks very much for tuning in and
we'll see you again
next week on windmill wednesday
you